The 12 principles of green
chemistry shown here.
Substances in the foremost
of the substance use and a
chemical process should be
chosen to minimize the
potential for accidents,
chemical accidents including
releases, explosions and fires. Okay.
Um, we've talked a lot about the nature
of feedstocks and nature of energy than
nature of waste. Um, but
not so much about accidents.
And yet, uh, accidents
are kind of consequential.
Um, this is one of the, uh,
the worst accidents.
Um,
and certainly in US history,
Texas city,
Texas.
So it was a shipping,
a shipping ammonium nitrate,
and you have a giant barge
shitting on the, on the harbor of,
uh,
Texas city,
Texas doc and ammonium
nitrate is a fine powder.
And the one thing you don't want us to,
to have that power to turn to dust.
So there's,
there's a lot of ways to, to
cover or contain that powder, um,
in order to make sure you don't get dust.
One of the things that you could contain
and coat that that powder with is do
you have and others it's wax
could cover and contain it with wax,
but you don't want to do that.
And nobody has ever done that again
since Texas city taxes because pretty,
it's a pretty good a first approximation
to say there was no Texas city,
Texas. Uh, on April 17th, um,
almost 600 killed, 3,500
injured. Uh, when this,
this blew up, this explosion
took place. Also had again, a
ammonium nitrate explosion. And
this isn't to loose France. Uh,
3.4 on the Richter scale,
uh,
over 2000 injured, 30 killed 800 plus
hospitalized in Toulouse, France,
uh,
27,000 housing units.
This was a Wharton international,
the subsidiary of the Morton Salt,
uh,
commercial, just in case you don't
think thinking can happen in Manhattan.
This happened about 10 years ago,
uh, uh, in Manhattan. This is, um,
this was waste dispose this
one, is it a paper mill? Uh,
so different kinds of reactive hazards.
Um,
this is chemical processing in Montana.
That's his first chemical.
This was only minor injuries,
but of course the plant was a
itself ruined specialty plastics.
So we've got paper, we've got
plastics, we've got uh, uh,
the one in Manhattan, I think it was
printing, uh, insulation products.
This is a gun about 10 years ago.
Combustion explosion repackaging.
Okay.
So I'm going to tell you about love
canal. Who knows about Lumpkin? Anybody?
I feel like I'm almost
in a history lesson,
but don't consider this a history lesson
because we're going to see that this is
all too relevant today.
Love Canal neighborhood in
upstate New York back in 1950,
300 chemical soul,
the plot of land for a dollar to the
town after dumping 21,000 tons of toxic
waste into this,
this hand,
it took until the sediments
kill all of the miscarriages.
The neurotoxic effect in
the cancers came to light.
Uh, and it was declared an
ecological disaster area essentially.
And the federal government had to
locate or relocate 800 families.
They had to essentially by the time,
uh,
because it was an environmental disaster.
Anyway.
Okay.
Hi, speech time speech Missouri.
This was the early eighties.
So what chemical company
that a waste hauler and said,
we want you to get a bit of our waste,
paid him $3,000 for a truck load to
get rid of their hazardous waste.
And they decided, well, for dust control,
we're going to split this
hazardous waste on the dusty roads.
And this one happened to be an area
that's a little bit before a flood,
a flood prone cuts into the
drinking water. Dioxin levels are,
we're 2000 times higher than that file.
An Agent Orange, a
chemical warfare agent, uh,
again, can Swiss miss
characters neurotoxic effects.
And a 1983, the, uh,
the government had the purchase the
town for $32 million the entire town and
everybody was essentially
an environmental refugees.
The Cuyahoga River,
the Cuyahoga River as a,
uh, is anybody from Ohio. Um,
so the Cuyahoga or whatever, it doesn't
look like this anymore, luckily,
but in 1969, uh, person to play it,
it's not the first time in person
to his first and to planes a lot.
But in 1969, a picture was taken
to made the cover of life magazine,
which was big at the time.
And, and people said, you know,
we don't want an owl river is
bursting into flames. Uh, that's,
that's bad.
Um,
and so my favorite slogan about,
um,
the Cuyahoga river is it
somebody said in the Cuyahoga,
you don't, if you pull it and you
don't so much drown as d components,
um,
it was just that pollutant.
Okay.
So just in case you think that this is
a history lesson and that these things
don't exist today,
let's talk about some
of the Aternity today.
Today in our chemical products,
consumer products,
electronic products, we are using
chemicals that are capable of disrupting,
uh, eloquent system, reproductive
and developmental, uh, of,
of fetuses to the point where the
composition of these chemicals that are
playing a role as to whether or not,
for instance,
I will be a grandparent,
whether or not my project,
you will be able to reproduce.
They will influence what the
Iq of your children might be.
That's absurd.
And we can talk a lot
more about that right now.
If mother's milk were attempted to be
sold on the shelves as regular milk,
it's too contaminated in many,
many countries with the impurities are
persistent bioaccumulative and toxic
substances. Remember we talked about
the body garden and all of us, um,
have these persistent
bioaccumulative and toxic substances.
They tend to accumulate in
fat and mother's milk as a
depository for that.
And many of these products are either
directly applied to or meant for children.
Uh, we'll talk about things
such as Piss Spinall,
a in baby bottles and different valets
and rubber duckies and the consequences
of those,
those substances today,
not in the 80s, none in
the 70s. None of the 50s
talks about pharmaceutical ways.
We mentioned that.
What about pharmaceuticals in the
environment, not just for manufacturing,
but when all pharmaceuticals are
throw it away and use pharmaceuticals,
the ones that are in your body that can
excrete it now have biologically active
levels of pharmaceuticals
in the environment and
things such as our drinking
water.
Okay.
Industrial chemicals in
rivers and streams of,
I have the example of his 77%.
The small mouth bass from the
Mississippi River are Intersex. Intersex,
but they,
because of these endocrine disrupting
chemicals are believed to be changing
gender.
These are also affecting the
Florida panthers. 90%, uh,
of the, uh, of have this farm is abnormal
in developing countries. 70% of the
industrial waste dumped untreated into
the water.
In 2010,
the noise generated 30 million tons of
plastic waste and 7% was recovered from
the cycling.
Okay.
And this is our current energy portfolio.
Talk about,
yeah.
Whether it's Fukushima, whether
it's the BP oil spill, um,
coal mining. Um, we have quite a, a
series of unintended consequences.
Somebody tells me what Paul Paul is.
Why do we care about both hall?
That's the likes of Simon.
How's it was chemical
ruptured valve was helping.
People are still hand waving as to
exactly what it was. When you caught by.
Would love to say that it's sabotage.
I have no idea. I don't really care.
What we should all care about is that
when this toxic gas was released,
uh,
5,000 were killed immediately.
5,000 people died
immediately in their homes.
It's estimated that another 18,000
died in the following two weeks.
And the thousands more diet of,
uh, diseases related to the,
the gas poisoning all the time.
Think of the worst terrorist
tragedy that we could imagine. Uh,
that's happened.
It doesn't compare to this
things that we restructure
our laws and our society about,
uh,
doesn't compare to this.
When you take a look at the potential
for accidents like this today,
not them today,
the potential what chemical accidents,
um,
that can kill many thousands of
people instantly still exist.
I'd recommend that everybody take
five, 10 minutes or go to the, uh,
something called the Chemical
Safety Board website.
It will take you through all
of the chemical accidents
that are happening today
that'll run order investigation,
west Texas where people
will, uh, 15 people were,
were killed instantly and
level of the town year ago. Uh,
and Alon Alon.
Uh,
my biggest challenge is understanding
why everybody isn't a up in arms about a
West Virginia and why that is somehow
to my perspective being taken by her too
much in this dry. Uh, but
the, the point of this,
this class,
this whole course is not a
two to rail against the bad,
but to use the tools of green chemistry
to invent a different path and to
understand the situation as it is in
order to design things so that they're
different in the future.